we're asked to write 7/8 as a decimal
and as a percent well we'll start off
with a decimal and we'll see it's pretty
easy to go from a decimal to a percent
now whatever you see a problem like this
it's sometimes confusing like what G how
do I even get it into you know decimal
or is a fraction over 100 or as a
percentage and you always have to
remember 7 over 8 or 7/8 is the exact
same thing 7 over 8 is the exact same
thing this means literally 7/8 not 8/7
7/8 the numerator divided by the
denominator and you say well how do I
turn that into a decimal well we just
literally do a long division problem but
we keep going behind the decimal point
so that we don't end up with a remainder
or until we end up with things repeating
you'll see what we mean in this case we
won't end up with anything repeating so
let's try this out so it's 7 divided by
8 so it's 7 7 divided by 8 so how many
times does 8 go into 7 well 8 does not
go into 7 it goes 0 times and actually
just so that we make sure that
everything is clean let's put our
decimal you could view this as 8 going
into seven point zero zero zero and you
can keep adding as many zeros as you
need until you're done dividing so we
have our decimal point will be right
here right where the right behind the
seven where it was up here so we say
eight goes into seven zero times zero
times eight is zero
you subtract 7 minus zero is 7 now we
can bring down a zero we bring down a
zero it becomes 70 and then you say
eight goes into 70 how many times well 8
times 8 is 64 so that works 8 times 9 is
72 that's too big so it goes into it
eight times so it goes into it eight
times 8 times 8 is 64 when you subtract
70 minus 64 is six is six well you still
have a remainder so let's keep going
let's bring down another zero so you
bring down another zero right over there
and so you say how many times is it
going to 60
eight times eight is sixty-four so
that's too big 8 times 7 is 56 so
that'll work so it goes into 60 seven
times seven times eight is fifty-six
you subtract 60 minus 56 is four so we
still have a remainder so let's keep
bringing down some zeros so let's bring
this zero down here and 8 goes into 40
how many times well eight times five is
forty so it goes in nice and evenly so
it goes into it five times five times
eight is forty subtract no remainder so
as a decimal we just figured out that
seven eight which is equal to 7/8 is
exactly zero point eight seven five so
it is equal to so seven eight seven over
eight as a decimal is equal to zero
point eight seven five now we've done
the decimal part now the next thing is
to do a percent and if you have it as
the decimal doing as a percent is very
easy
you literally shift the decimal place
two to the right and you put a percent
sign there and I think it makes sense
why it works because now you're going to
say how many per hundred this is you
could view this as eight hundred and
seventy-five thousandths or you could
view this let me write this down you
could view this as a fraction you could
say well this is the same thing as 875
over a thousand right that's how we've
read it in the past this is the thousand
spot right here
875 over thousand or you could read this
as eighty seven point five over 100 you
could see if you just go to decimal
places it's eighty seven point five over
100 or if you just took this and you
divided the numerator in the denominator
by 10 you would get this and this is
literally saying eighty seven point five
per 100 so this second statement right
here this is literally saying eighty
seven point five per 100 or per cent so
this is equal to 87 point 5 per cent so
that gives you the reasoning for why it
works but the really easy way if you
have a decimal to make it into a percent
you
shift that you just literally multiply
the number by a hundred and put the
percent there which is essentially kind
of telling you that you're going to
divide by hundred so you're multiplying
and dividing by a hundred so if you
literally you multiply this by 100 which
is equivalent to shifting the decimal
place two places to the right that
literally will become 87 0.5 eighty
seven point five then you want to put
the percent this says this is going to
be over 100 so you multiply by 100 and
then divided by hundred you're not
really changing the number hopefully
that makes sense another way to remember
because sometimes you might get confused
do I put the decimal to the right do I
take it to the left is that the decimal
representation will always be smaller
than the percent representation and not
only will it be smaller but it'll be
followed by exactly a factor of 100
right you well this is a hundred times
smaller of a number right here than just
the 87.5 obviously when you put this
percent here these become the exact same
number